underneath the turkish region of
cappadocia a system of hidden tunnels
and caves went undiscovered for a
thousand years until one man decided to
renovate his home
[Music]
eighteen stories below the ground level
in the turkish region of cappadocia is
the ancient hidden city derenkuyu
the city was rediscovered in 1963
when a man knocked down a wall in his
basement and stumbled across a hidden
room
this triggered an excavation of the area
to reveal the hidden city that is a
thousand years old and over 280 feet
deep
it is thought to have been created
during the byzantine era around 1000 a.d
to protect the community from wars and
natural disasters
it is made up of a network of tunnels
connecting what would have been kitchens
stables churches wells and even schools
the cappadocia region is known for
subterranean safe havens and it's
speculated that dan and kuyu may have
connected many of them
the city likely could have hidden 20 000
people livestock and food supplies
making it the largest underground city
in cappadocia
you